Richard Taggart?
[gunshot]
TV REPORTER: This flag
belongs to the Uma
movement, the group
claiming credit
for Richard Taggart's shooting.
Is that the same flag?
It damn sure is.
That's Michael Nasry.
How did you do it?
[screaming]
SIGINT traced the call
giving the kill order on Rip.
This was a guy on the
other end, Dragan Baruti.
We're awaiting confirmation
of his exact location.
We have a CIA
officer on the ground
with Dragan's girlfriend.
- He's running.
PILOT: They're evading.
Roger 2-1 fighting
left and flanking them.
I need Reagan alive.
Do you copy?
I need him alive.
Turn around.
Bomb.
I got some sort
of code book here.
WOMAN: That notebook
the Seals found,
gold mine, numbers,
names, operational plans.
Dragon and Muttaqi worked
for our favorite ghost.
Prince.
That guy's name was
in Dragan's notebook.
Highest level Jihadist
connected to the prince
we've ever bagged.
We have him in
custody in Romania.
Hello, Michael.
Let's get you out of here.